[Musique]
journée exceptionnelle pour une mise à
l'honneur des femmes pompiers dans
l'ouest de l'île professionnels
volontaires agents administratifs
bénéficie d'un moment convivial pour
échanger sur leurs actions
bah je crois que les femmes apportent
leur côté féminin
une vue une approche peut-être un peu
différente de celle des hommes tout en
sachant que nous travaillons dans un
corps de pompiers la majorité de nos
collègues sont des hommes
250 personnes soit 10% des effectifs
participe activement au quotidien à ce
corps sandra est pompier volontaire
depuis dix ans quand j'interviens je
vois les sourires des kaka kaka county
merci par rapport à mon intervention
c'est ça qui m'importe des tirs que
parce que je suis une femme il faut que
je suis en avant non ça m'intéresse pas
on aimerait bien que les gens nous
voient pas dans comme le maillon faible
du dé certains métiers on est aussi
capable de faire aussi bien que les
hommes
et sinon mieux à l'intérieur de la salle
s'engage un débat à bâtons rompus pour
ses agents au service de la population
chacune peut échanger sur l'expérience
de l'autre et cela en présence de grands
témoins pendant très longtemps il ya eu
des corps qui ont été interdits aux
femmes
les pompiers entre autres c'est depuis
seulement somme 16 où on peut avoir des
pompiers femmes et seulement je crois
qu'en 1990 qui a vu la première sapeurs
pompiers professionnels
donc c'est c'est quand même tout à fait
un peu intéressants et c'est aussi un
corps de métier qui reste très masculin
donc d'être alacchi et c'est important
que les familles entrent aussi pour
donner un autre voilà notre vision des
choses et surtout que notre société il
faut qu'elle avance co-présidée par le
département et la préfecture le service
départemental d'incendié et de secours
compte 2500 agents un lieu
d'épanouissement professionnel et social
les femmes qui se retrouvent aujourd'hui
sans métier peuvent se tourner vers ce
métier là parce que je voulais
rencontrer des femmes conflit est là
aujourd'hui et des femmes qui
travaillent dans le milieu qui sont tout
à fait pas nous y en tant que femme en
tant que maman en tant que
volontaires ou professionnels je pense
que c'est un bon parcours et qu'il faut
aller vers ce métier là et de découvrir
sa demande à être connu la journée de la
femme est donc également le temps des
opportunités cette médiatisation ouvrira
peut-être d'autres perspectives au sein
des pompiers 9 7 4
[Musique]